[Music]
taiwan has a constitution
an army and an elected government yet
the united nations doesn't formally
recognize it
the reason china considers the island
one of its provinces
the government as illegitimate and talk
of independence
deeply hostile a new president in taipei
from the independent leaning democratic
progressive party is
testing china's tolerance as is a new
president in washington here's the
situation
taiwan's first female president sai
ingwen provoked an
angry response from china by speaking to
donald trump by telephone after he was
elected
in deference to the beijing government
no u.s leader has talked directly to a
taiwan president
in almost four decades tsai says she
wants peaceful ties with china
while resisting pressure to acknowledge
the one china principle
that principle has underpinned relations
with china in the past
it's the understanding that both sides
belong to one china
even if they have different ideas about
what that means
trump says his support for one china
policy hinges on cutting a better trade
deal with china
prompting a complaint from the chinese
government i don't know why we have to
be
bound by one china policy unless we make
a deal
with china tsai is promising to follow
public opinion on china
polls show strong support for
maintaining the status quo
of coexistence and little immediate
interest in independence
here's the argument taiwan's 23
and a half million people have built
their economy into a technology and
manufacturing
powerhouse average income three times
out of china's
and much of apple's iphone made there
voters turned to psy
to keep the peace while building
international ties
with a view to a future less dependent
on the mainland
while many china watchers say there's
too much at stake for military
confrontation
trump's election has added a degree of
uncertainty to the old assumptions
an increasingly assertive china aims
more than 1
200 missiles at taiwan and no peace
treaty has been signed
in the seven decades since the
government split
for the u.s some analysts say supporting
the one china policy
has allowed it to sell weapons to taiwan
and that's helped deter china from
attempting to retake the island by force